[Music]
our email has been
hacked the attackers broke into the mail
server and gained full access to our
personal correspondence all confidential
messages and accounts associated with
the mailbox ended up in the Hacker's
hands but we were
prepared in fact we deliberately created
this mailbox to lure the hackers in and
tried to track them
down here's how we did it and what we
[Music]
found this video was created by sus up
the verification platform we make the
digital world people friendly yet
secure to find out how email is hacked
we decided to create a Honeypot a decoy
mail ma box for hackers we didn't use
public email services for two
reasons firstly if hackers changed the
account password we can't recover it
quickly on a public server secondly our
own mail server allows us to track when
and with which IP address it was
accessed to realize our idea we paid for
hosting and registered a new
domain then we created a mailbox in our
domain and organized correspondence in
that mailbox filling it with messages
from enron's email database to make it
appear as if it was in active
use we changed the names and domains in
the Enron messages and subscribed this
box to several popular mailing lists to
get more messages in
it according to the legend we invented
the owner of the box is an ordinary
programmer so his box contains business
and personal corresp respondence we
created the text of personal emails
using chat GPT artificial intelligence
did a pretty good job we placed an email
in our inbox with the subject line your
login and password in the hope that the
attacker would be interested and open
this
email inside the email we placed a
tracking pixel a transparent picture of
1 by one
pixel the hacker trap is ready let's see
if we can achieve something with these
methods
[Music]
you may have received messages claiming
to be from the administrators of your
mail server stating that your account
password is about to expire and needs to
be changed
immediately these emails are sent by
cyber criminals in the hope that you
will visit a fake website and enter your
login and mailbox password into a
fraudulent form which will then be
passed on to the hackers they send out
tens of millions of these emails every
day and we get these emails too let's
take a look at the code of this web page
we can see that another web page is
embedded in this web page and this in
turn contains a form created using this
free service with it you can create
various forms for feedback and data
collection well let's make the hackers
happy and enter our username and
password into this forum as well as our
mailbox address attackers who use Mass
fishing emails usually do not use hacked
mailboxes themselves but sell their
logins and passwords to other
hackers using a special website for
Information Security Professionals we
found other fishing forms and then
entered our email account login and
password into them we hope that this way
our chances of catching the hacker would
increase we filled out five forms in
total nothing happened for a few
days then on day four someone opened our
bait email our server recorded the IP
address of the device on which the email
was opened first of all we decided to
determine the geolocation of this IP
address to do this we use the
iplocation.net
service in Linux you can do this by
using this command in the terminal as we
can see this IP address is
geographically located in Russia kenrad
region however the definition of the
region where the hacker is to live does
not give us much also IP addresses can
be dynamic and belong to several
subscribers of one provider who access
the internet at different
times let's try to find out a little
more about this IP
address the service I know what you
download.com collects a database of
peers and SIDS of all public torrent
files which can be used to find out what
was recently downloaded from Torrent
from this IP address as we can see the
user with this IP address has downloaded
several pired Mac music applications
films such as The Walking Dead House MD
the boss baby and The Dark Knight this
user likes computer games such as
Flatout the Far Cry series and Sims 4 he
also seems to be a big fan of Joan
Rowling's work Google search engine
allows us to find a lot of useful
information on IP addresses to properly
generate an IP address search query
among the following sources public
directories configuration files
database
files
logs old data and backup
data authentication
Pages SQL
errors to find such information we will
use Google hacking tests and pent test
tools
Services the search was
[Music]
unsuccessful let's search for an IP
address in the leaked databases using
the leak lookup service no results
again so we found out that the user who
opened our tracker email is located in
Russia kaliningrad region connect to the
internet via T2 mobile provider also
this user or users on this IP probably
uses an Apple Mac computer Likes music
the game Far Cry Dr House series and
loves Harry Potter not much but that's
all we've been able to find
[Music]
out now let's try to find out how much
it costs to hack a mailbox to order and
how cyber criminals operate when their
goal is not to get as many cred
credentials as possible through Mass
mailings but to hack a specific person's
mailbox we will use online forums where
cyber criminals advertise their services
we will hire a hacker to hack into the
mailbox we have created we will monitor
his actions and find out what he's going
to do in most criminal forums
transactions are made through an escrow
a reputable intermediary the customer
transfers money to the escrow but he
does not pay the money to the executor
until the executor provides proof that
the order has been fulfilled the
intermediary Services typically cost 3
to 5% of the order value a study
conducted at the University of
California San Diego USA found the
following prices for email hacking as
you can see hacking mailboxes on Russian
public servers is the cheapest hacking
Gmail and Yahoo is the most
expensive we tried to find a hacker who
would hack into our mailbox and provide
evidence of the hack send an email email
from the Hacked mailbox or provide a
secret code from an email message we
sent to the
mailbox the hackers offered the
following items $400 for hacking the
email and a 50% Deposit they also asked
us to send them all the information we
know about this
user typically attackers use three
methods to break into emails brute
forcing forcing a password using a
dictionary this method does not work on
public email servers because they have
built-in Brute Force protections and in
other cases brute forcing is only
possible if the victim uses a simple
dictionary password by the way you can
learn more about real brute forcing
attacks in our previous
video next is searching for your
password in leaked databases from time
to time hackers steal user databases
from various services such as online
stores forums or delivery services such
databases are sold on the dark net many
of us use the same password for multiple
services including email Services if
attackers manage to find such a password
in the lead's databases they can use it
to gain unauthorized access to your
mailbox social engineering especially
fishing this is the most common
method one of the hackers we hired told
us a day later that he had successfully
hacked into our mailbox but that we had
seen no related activity as proof he
sent us an email reporting to be from
the Hacked mailbox the email turned out
to be fake if we look at the headers of
the email we can see that the address of
the sender of this message was forged
and it was sent from a completely
different mail server we informed the
hacker about this and he stopped
contacting us another hacker also told
us about a successful hack and his proof
sent us a screenshot of the Hacked
mailbox this screenshot was photoshopped
this is what the contents of the mail
actually look like we asked him to give
us the numerical code from the email we
sent to this address but he was unable
to do
so thus the two hackers turned out to be
scammers who collect payment from
hacking customers and do nothing because
they're sure that the customer will
definitely not go to the
police the third hacker tried to break
into our mailbox using Brute Force but
was unable to crack the password it
seems that during the attack the hacker
used a special program that sends
requests through proxy servers because
the authorization attempts can came from
different IP addresses after the Brute
Force attempt failed the hacker decided
to use social
engineering researchers at the
University of California San Diego have
identified five types of fishing emails
attackers typically impersonate a person
known to the victim a stranger a bank
Google or a government
agency the hacker we hired sent us three
fishing emails on behalf of LinkedIn
Xbox online and
Adobe the first email sent on behalf of
LinkedIn contain the link to a fishing
site with a fake authorization form the
address of this site is different from
linkedin's real
address the second fishing email
contains a link to another fake
authorization form the URL of this site
is also fake plus it contains our email
address if we change the email address
in the address bar it will also change
in the fishing authorization
form the link in the third email on
behalf of adobe didn't
work if we examine the page source of
these fake authorization form websites
we can see that the hacker has copied
the form of the real website
specifically LinkedIn and simply changed
the parameters of the form so that it
sends him the information entered in the
form
Fields We examined the source of the
fishing emails we received and found the
sender addresses was spoofed and the
technical headers of the emails contain
fake addresses like mail. example.com
we did not respond to these messages in
any way and a short time later we
received another one the link in this
email opens through several redirects
and then the user's browser is checked
by the cloudfare service before being
redirected to the Target page attackers
do this to confuse the users and their
antivirus
software in total we received five
fishing emails from the hacker since he
didn't know what services the mailbox
owner was using and we didn't give him
any additional information
he used the most popular services such
as LinkedIn and Microsoft fishing emails
can be distinguished by the following
characteristics the URL of the pages
linked to in the email differs from that
of the real site and the link may be
opened via several
redirects also indicative of fishing can
be urgent requests to confirm your
address or other personal information or
non-personal appeals such as dear
customer scammers who carry out targeted
fishing attacks hide out on hacker for
forums sending emails in the name of a
fake sender and therefore are Anonymous
it is literally impossible to identify
them so they feel completely safe the
main conclusion from this experiment is
that the hack is only successful if the
victim believes the scammers and enters
their login and password into the
fishing form created by the
attackers our experiment shows that
social engineering or fishing Remains
the primary method for compromising em
em accounts researchers at the
University of California have also found
that hackers can use malware to hack
email accounts namely rat remote
assistance tool a program that allows
them to take control of an infected
computer a modified version of Team view
can be used as a
rat therefore complex passwords in two
Factor authentication should be used to
protect against hacking the study we
quote States however we found that two
Factor Authentication still proved an
obstacle attackers doubled their price
upon learning An accounts had toofa
enabled at the same time hackers have
the tools to intercept 2 FAA onetime
codes in particular they can create fake
forms that verify these codes in real
time and use the resulting data for
authorization therefore using two Factor
authentication alone is not a guarantee
of security you should not click on
links in emails even on behalf of your
ISP or mail server administrator
if you do open such a link carefully
check the URL of the page it takes you
to it is also a good idea to use
antivirus software with a web antivirus
feature such programs use databases of
fraudulent addresses to block users from
accessing fake sites of course there is
a time lag between a moment when a
fishing site is created and when its
address is added into the antivirus
database but in some cases using
antivirus can be effective and provide
an extra layer of protection in addition
many public email Services have tools
against potential attackers for example
Gmail may ask you to enter the account
holder's phone number enter an SMS code
or solve a capture when you try to sign
in from a new device you should not
disable additional Security Options when
using these
Services PS while we were making this
video someone tried to connect to our
SMTP to send spam this is probably the
main reason why attackers send fishing
emails to everyone without a specific
purpose